はい それではよろしくお願いします
えっと  今まで大変な行儀よく
講演会の初めのセクションを行いましたけど
私は行儀が悪いので 国から乱暴なことを言われますので
大変 それではどうしましょうかね
はい 今日のテーマは幸福の道は友情で完成するというテーマで
ブッダの話をちょっと紹介したいと思ってます
思ってます それから あの
これ講演っていうのは初めてではなくてね
あの まあ何回 何回も同じテーマでね
人間関係はなんせとかね
友達とはなんせとか いろんなところでいろんなテーマで話してあるし
またあの本も出てるような気がします
私は書かないんだから
自分が書く本がね あんまり役に立ちませんから
読んだって で 何者かとこんな変なものを書くのは自分で思いますけどね
まあとにかくあの 友人とはなんぞやということ
人間関係はどうあるべきかということは
あの一応あの経典とかテキストにも書いてあります
何とこんがりまたね あの在京の方々にね
まあブッダのそういうテーマで
おそらくそのテーマですね
あ ブッダの生命の教えというタイトルでね
詳しいところはあの そういうところを参考になさって参考にしてみればお分かりになると思います
うん それから今日の話
講演の内容はね もうとっくにあの
ビデオで流しちゃったんですよ
もう何 私は何を言えばいいんですかね
私の内容で全部流しちゃったんですね
だから私はだいたいこの講演の材料なんかは
ギリギリまで誰にもあげませんし
まあ一応皆様方は あの
かなりあの専門的に能力を駆使して作ったスッパナ材料で
内容は一番あのご存知だと思います
はい それで私はそれと全く違う内容をしゃべってやろうかなと思います
逆にです でお釈迦様が称賛する良き仲間とは
あの いきなりこの経典紹介します
今まで順番に行って 最後に結論を言うんです
今日は結論を先に言って
暇があったら理由を言います
宗教のやり方でね 宗教というのは結論を先に言うんです
それでわからない 信仰しなさいというね
だから結論から言います
あのカリアニッタスッタという教がありまして
あのサングティニカーののね
サカトワの 3番目のセクションであのでコーサラサンゲタというんです
その中で 2番目のセクションで 8番目の経典です
ややこしいですね サングティニカーでどこにあるかわからないですよね
まあ一応パーリ聖典はそういうふうに分類してあって
あの勉強する方々はよく知っていると思います
この西洋に対する経典ですね
経典はあの まあつぐらいあります
そこであの いくらか順番的に構成しているような感じでね
その経典の中で もっとまとめて
最終的に一般バージョンという感じで
このこのところでコーサラさんに行ったところで入ってます
この経典は友情についてお釈迦様が語られたお話ですね
コーサラ国王の言葉と
はい この経典はコーサラ王様とコーサラ国の国王とお釈迦様の対話なんです
もうそれからそういうふうに対話しちゃったんですね
もうわけもわかんない言葉だから読まないでください
あのイダマイアンダンテラーフラパティサリーナセーワンチェーソーパリッタウデバーリ
スワーナトゥダンマターダンモソーチャコーカリャニッタスカルヤ
サハヤスカリダノサンパワンカッセノパーパミッパッセノパーパサハヤッセノパーパサンパワンカッサティという
で この王様はそういう意見をお釈迦様に言うんです
これわからないね 尊師
私は一人でいた時 いわゆる王様も時々一人になりたいんですよ
で 一人でいた時はこのような考えが起きましたと
なんか一人で考えて一人でいるとなんかあること考えちゃったんですね
釈迦さんは真理を見事に完全に説かれている
お釈迦様っていうのはすごいことを教えられている
真理を見事に 完璧に しかし
その教えは専有がいる人に
専有に従う人に通じるもので
悪有がいる人に 悪有に従う人に通じるものではありません
ブッダはお釈迦様がどんな立派に真理を語っても
結局は戦力がいなかったら何の意味もないんだと
あの こういうことですね
皆様にね まあ弁当を 美味しい弁当をあげても
お箸をくれなかったらどうする？舐める
あのワンちゃん食べるように食べる？困るでしょ
で だからね 立派な弁当であっても
お箸ぐらいはつけてくれないと
そういう感じで この国王が言うのは
やっぱり専有が過ぎていると
仏道のブッダの教えの意味がものすごくわかります
まあいい友達がなかったらまあしょうがないかと
もう仏教はどういうことかとわからなくなっちゃいますよ
あの お釈迦様の教えっていうのは
ずっと隠してないんですよ
皆様に誰にも えーと 皆様に誰にでもわかるように本も書いてるし
英訳もあるし フランス語の訳もあるし
あの結構翻訳はついてますよ
テキストはいくらでもありますけど
しかし誰一人お釈迦様が何を仰ってるかと理解してないんですね
で こうではないかああではないかと思ったりするんですね
別に結構です 思わなくてもちゃんと本書いてますからね
お釈迦様こういうことをおっしゃってます
そこは置いといて お釈迦様はもしかするとこういう風に言ったんではないかと思ったりもする
とにかく仏教というのはなかなか理解しないということが世の中でよくあることで
要はやっぱりお箸がなくって弁当だけくれたような感じなんですね
これはちょっとどうしたら食べた方がいいかわからなくなっちゃいますね
そういうことで 専有があれば仏教はどういうことかと理解できるようになります
それで私はそこをちょっと解説してみます
王は仏教が完全無欠に傾いていることに
また 説かれたとおりの結果を間もないうちに得られることに喜んでいたんですね
王様っていうのは暇人ですかね
こんな仏教のことを考えたりする暇があるということはね
まあ暇人ではなく けど
やっぱり直々お釈迦様に会って仲良くすることができたんだから
すごい この人間っていうのは
理性のある智恵のある
大事なことを喋る人っていうのはとても大事なんですね
ですから 王様っていうのは
お釈迦様 王様がお釈迦様と親しくするのはすごく好きなんですね
誰がまとめた話できるんだから
役に立つ話 ですから この王様の視点で考えると
ブッダの教えっていうのはすごい教えで
見事に結果が出てる出るんですね
おっしゃっている通り
結果といった人の人生がすごく幸福になる
とは言っても みんな幸福かというとそうでもないんですね
だって ここは一人で考えるので
ブッダの話を聞いているのに
なんで一部の人々はそのままざらしじゃなくて
欲に染めてもう悪い苦しい生活をしているのかと
なぜ一部の人々は仏道を歩んですごい幸福になっているのかというと
やっぱりそれが洗脳の問題である
しかし その実践は一人だけでは到底実践できるものではないのです
慈しみと智慧が備わっている善玉善友の導きが必要なのです
無知の悪人なら 仏道に逆らうことを勧めるのです
結局ね あの まあ私たちも長い人生の中で
あの結構経験ありますからね
もうそろそろこの地球から私のことを追い出されると思いますけど
先があまりにも短くなっちゃったんです
だから 今まで生きてきた方々でよくわかることは
何か いかにブッダの言葉を馬鹿にしようかどうかね
ブッダの道 生きる道をね
否定しようかということに世の中は必死なんですね
よく言うのは そんなこと言ったって
まあこの現代世界ではね
こんな古臭い教えは実践できるわけがないんだと
ね 科学者は言ってないんだから
縁起なんかありっこはないんだとかね
科学者はブッダになってくるわけ
私は聞きたくなるんですけどね
そういうふうな話ばっかりなんですね
私はそれたとえ話で考えるんですよ
うちのお子さんが大根嫌いだから
大根というのは人類の毒だよというような話なんですね
誰かさんが若くない 誰かさんが気に入らないんだから
みんなでやめてくださいというふうな話で
まあなかなかね いろんな人々は頑張っているのは
いかにブッダの道を世界に知らせないで
もうゴミ箱にどうすれば捨てられるのかということしか考えてない
で こういうことが例にあります
質問なんですけど あの
自分の小さな娘さんが夜突然怖くなっちゃって
お母さん死ぬのが怖いと泣き出しちゃったと
だから このお母さん ずっと自分のそばにいてくださいと
それから自分のお母さんにいてほしいとか何とかとか
子供はいろいろ言ったところで
このお母さんがまあこの際
本当のことを教えなければちゃということで
娘さんにあのね 人は誰でも死にますよとかね
死ぬことだけは誰も逆らえませんよとかね
それは覚悟した方がいいんだとかいろいろ言ったようです
今まで仏教を学んだこと
そうすると 家の方々はお母さんに怒られて
あなたは子供を洗脳しているんではないかといって
お母さんも怖くなって迷い込む
と 実際私は子供を洗脳しているのでしょうか？と
私の返事は 人類は初めからアダムとイブから生まれましたと
厳しいことを書いてないんだけど
皆様にちょっともうちょっと伸ばして言います
人類というのはみんな親戚相関という罪を感じているんだと
だって同じ兄弟 同じ親の子供ですからね
そういうことを言うと
マインドコントロールとか洗脳
洗脳するとか全然いいません
バージンでありながら子供が生まれるんだと言うと
また不思議だ また不思議だとか
それは信仰する  12月25日
サンタクロースがプレゼントを持ってくると
そんなことを言うのはいいんです
人は誰でも死ぬんだということをあかん
そんな嘘をこの世界で我々は生きているんです
だから あの 仏教はマインドコントロールにちんもないんです
ただ本当のことを言ってるだけ
それにみんな腹が立つんです
しょうがないんです だから皆様は本当に幸せな方々で
もうおそらく億年くらい寿命が延びるでしょうとか言った方が気分がいい
で なんでね 嘘ばっかし人間の頭に叩き込んで叩き込んで
この幻想の世界で生きてますけど
だからこのいつでもブッダの教えを本当の真理だと知るためには
厳しく誰かと話し合わなくちゃいけないんですね
それから実践する時でも
誰かからちょっともう先にやってきた人からまあ聞いてもらった方がいいということはあります
そのもう一つポイントありますけど
ちょっと難しいんだから今日はちょっと控えます
それでお釈迦様が賛成するのですね
エウメタマーラでエウメタマーラでソワカトダンモと前にあった文章なんですけど
省略して出ます 仏教が語る幸福の境地に達することは
善友がいる人に 善友のアドバイスを受ける人にのみできるのです
厳しい条件です ブッダが言ってる究極の幸福に達したければ
善友が必要だよ 一人で成長しようと思う人は
その方法も一人で考えなくてはならないんです
これ知ってるでしょ？ちょっと真剣に考えてください
ある人が私に当たり前に来るという必要はないんだ
私は自分で考えて頑張ります
すごい独立精神 いる人はいますよ
私は自分で将来の自分の将来の人生設計しますと
自分で考えて生きてますと
自分で判断します 自分で成長しますと言ってもできない
これ先にその理由を書くんです
しかし 成長していない未熟な心で成長に達する方法は考えられません
だから 自分がまだまだ未熟で
勉強もできなくて まだ勉強していない
未熟 何もできない 人生経験もない
はい これから私が自分で育てるぞと言っても
これは不可能なんです
自分の人生設計を未熟な心で
不完全な心で 発展していない間違ったところで作らなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから成り立たないんですよ
で 建物の設計を作る場合は
それはそれなりのプロが設計作るんでしょう
描くんでしょう だから我々はどう生きるべきかということは
俺が自分で考えますよというのはありえない話です
しかし みんなそこをやろうとするんです
結局はどこかでモヤモヤすぎて
人生はダメになっちゃうんです
で だからやっぱり論理的に私たちには誰かがやっぱり
経験ある人は導いた方がよろしいということになります
はい それからお釈迦様とこの国王の対話は続けていきます
そこで国王が言いましたからね
善友がいれば 仏道は実践できますと言ったら
お釈迦様はこのアーナンダ尊者の話を国王に言うんです
あのね 国王さん 知ってますかね
アーナンダ尊者 こんなこと言った
言ってましたよ 釈国のナガラカという村に釈尊が大祭中
アーナンダ尊者がこのように釈尊に報告をするんです
これをお釈迦様が言うんですよ
国王と国王 この間 私はね
自分の国に帰って ナガラカという村に行った
住んでたんだと 住んでてまた大祭してました
その時 アーナンダ尊者が来てこんなことを言うんだ
こう言う ウパーリダンバーンテーブラフマチャリアスヤリダンカリャーニミッタカリャーナサハエタカリャーナサンパワンカタ
善友がいれば 善友に従えば仏道は半分も進みますよ
いわゆる悟りに達する道
アーナンダ尊者いいことを考えちゃったんです
もし助けてくれる人がいれば
いいアドバイザー 友達がいれば
まあ修行はざーっと半分ぐらい進みますよ
お釈迦さんに褒めてもらいたかったでしょうね
そんなことをいいことを考えちゃったということでどうなったんですかね
お釈迦様の答え アーナンダ
そのように決して言ってはならない
あんた何言うのか とんでもないこと
まあ平和 アーナンダ まあ平和がすごい
もう二回も断ったんです
言ってはならない そういう言葉は
サカラミエナギガンアーナンダブラフマチャリアンヤリガンカリャーニミッタカリャーナサハエタカリャーナサンパワンカタ
善友がいること 善友に従うことは
仏道においてはすべてであります
お釈迦様でございます
半分じゃないんです 解脱に達するまで
悟り開くまで専修が必要です
専修がいればもう完璧に悟れます
解脱に達しますということなんです
だから専修が無きにして
何の幸福もないということなんです
もっと言い換えれば 我々の人生はそれで決めます
神を信じるかないかではないんです
神を信じないならば地獄に行く
信じたらもう極楽に落ちます
と決まってはいるんだけど
それに関係なく あの自分に専修があれば
何でもかんでも成功するんです
幸福になるんです 成功はどんな方面でもよろしいのです
財産的でも何でも 知識でも何でもいいんです
例えば勉強 学問成就したいなら
学者としてもう立派になりたいと思うならば
決定点検は善友が持っているんです
何でも善友で決めます
私はそのポイントを時々人を判断することにも使いますよ
特にこの若者というのは
この年寄りとはなかなか喋れないんですね
全部隠すんですね お母さんたちでもね
もう子供たち何も言いませんよ
ごまかしてるんです お母さんに
歳 歳まではあれこれできてますけどね
どんどん大きくなってくると
いろんなこと言わないで隠しちゃって
ただちょっとごまかしだけに
もう親と関係を持つんです
しかし 親っていうのは心配なんでしょ
だからもう年寄りはみんなみんな若者のこと心配するんですよ
ちゃんと勉強しているのかとかね
ちゃんとうまくいってるのかとか
あれやこれやとか心配です
それでこの若者が何も言ってくれないんだから性格わからないです
だから助けてあげたいんだけど
どのように助けてあげればいいかわからない
それでいいポイントがあります
この若者たちの仲間が何なのか
誰と付き合ってるんですか？とか
どんな種類の友達作ってるのかと
仲間を見ればいいんです
例えば自分のうちの子はすごくすごく決まって
服とかね もう本当にしっかりとまとめに大人しく着ていても
その友達の自分の子供の友達がいるんですね
あまりにも大胆で 派手な服装で
頭の見た目の一部剃って一部伸ばして
髪の毛一部金髪にして
一部一部青い色にして
一部結んで あれやこれやとかね
まあそういう風にも 体中穴開けてね
いろんな金属の輪っか入れたりとか
そういうもう派手な服装の友達がうちの子供にいるんだと
しかし うちの子はしっかりとまあおとなしい服装でいるんだから大丈夫やじゃないんです
なんでこんなすごい突飛なことをする人と友達になったんですかね
だからやがてその子もそうなっちゃうんです
うちのおとなしい子 だからそういうことで
この我が子の心の中の好みは読めちゃうんです
友達を見ると で 心の中読めたらそれから指導できますよ
それからまあ なんのことなく
お母さんが息子にもね
あなたもね ちょっとぐらいおしゃれしてもいいよとかね
ちょっとちょっとぐらいはふざけた服装でも構いませんよ
ちょっと緩めてあげた方がいいんですね
これはお母さん怒るんだから真面目にいるんであって
お母さんの意図が聞いた途端
何するかわからないんだから
最初からそうやってアドバイスして
不幸にならないように守ってくることができます
ですから とにかくあの人の人生っていうのは友人で決めてしまいますよ
危ないんです 危ないったって
それは法則でしょう ですから
この友人との関係っていうのは致命的なんです
生きるか死ぬかどっちかって決めてしまいますね
だから我々は根本的に
いつでも良い仲間を選ばなくてはいけないことになります
だけど お釈迦様は言うのは
すべて悟りに達するまで
決定権は指導権は善友が握っている
善友がいる人にこそ 正八正道を実践することを完成することを期待できるのです
ここで私は今日説明しないことにはしましたけど
この聖なる八正道 お釈迦様がこのまあ料理は料理することぐらいとかね
家の掃除 洗濯ぐらいは善友のアドバイスなくてもできますよ
それからもう何か外国語でも勉強したければ
もう本屋さんから本を買いてね
買ってきてね まあ独学でもそれなりにできないわけじゃないんです
漫画描きたければね 漫画を教えてくれる本もありますからね
そういう本を買ってきて
どのように漫画描けばよろしいかと一人で練習をすれば
まあできないわけでもないんですが
善友の指導がなく全く
全く不可能なのはこの聖なる八正道なんです
この聖なるということから気をつけてください
皆様はよく八正道 八正道と聞いているでしょ？仏道という八正道である
まあ皆さん覚えているでしょうね
まあ正見 正思惟とかね
で それからサンマ正語とかね
正語 正語 正命 まああるある
正精進  正定  少年少女  少年と少女
日本語で覚えてないんだから間違います
私はね はい その八正道はだいたいよくご存知です
しかし これに性入れちゃうとどうでしょう
この性なるという この暗示を入れたらどうなるでしょう
これが専有の指導がなくてできないんです
あの正語ぐらい正しい言葉を語る
語る そんなの難しくないでしょ
私が喋る喋る 私が喋れないようにね
もうちょっとまともに喋れば正語なんです
わかりやすく文法を間違えないで喋ればいいでしょ
しかし それでは悟れませんよ
まあ正思惟も正見とかね
まあ誰でもまあ正見はそんなに大げさな問題じゃないでしょ
正しい見解 物事に対して正しい見方を持っているとかね
例えば新型インフルエンサーインフルエンザにかかりたくないならば
新しくワクチン開発していますから
ワクチンの注射をしてもらったらよろしいでしょう
あるいはマスクをつけていればいいんじゃないかなともね
それぐらいの正見というのはいくらでもあるでしょう
しかし それでは悟りには達しないのです
この我々が毎日実践しているサンマーディティサンマーサンカパサンマーワーチャーというこの八正道が
レベルを高くして解脱へと導かれるように調整することが専有でしかできない
なんか難しいんだからわかりやすくします
例えば嘘をしてはついてはいけないでしょ
で あのいけないという話です
皆様はどうかわかりませんがだけどね
一応世の中ではそういう意味で嘘をついてはいけないと
その八正道の正語にあります
では 人が嘘をつかない
それ悟りますかね 別につくことないでしょ
嘘をつかないと言ったってね
自慢できることでもないし
結構いますよ 面白いことを嘘をつかない人々
なんか頭がどうかなっているかわかりませんだけどね
本当にいます 世の中 あの嘘つかない人って
だからといってどうっていうことはないんですよ
だから何をといきたいんですね
まあまあ 例えば殺生しない人もいるし
あの殺生しない人っていうのはちょっと珍しいんですけど
まああの菜食主義者は結構いますよ
あの卵も食べませんし
乳製品も食べませんと
あの菜食主義だから しかし殺生はします
だから菜食主義者は必ずしもあの慈悲の実践しているというわけじゃないんです
あの虫もパチパチと殺しちゃうしね
しかし 俺は卵も食べませんよと自慢もするし
この菜食主義ではなくて
本当に殺生しない人々というのはいますよ
すごく清く しかし 殺生しないでいたってもね
だからどうっていうことにならないんですよ
まあまあまあ いいじゃないということで終わっちゃうんです
私は盛り上げようね あなたは頑張ってください
私はやっぱり蚊に蚊が刺しちゃうとね
もうパチッとやっちゃいます
あなた あなたは頑張ってください
いう程度なんですね 問題は殺生しないこと
この単純なこと 嘘をつかないという
この単純なの ただ 邪な行為をしない
そんなに難しいことじゃないでしょ
その単純なこと ここを結構世の中に守るんですよ
まあ例えばあまりモテないね
男性女性っていうのは性欲をひどく抑えちまってるよ
だからちゃんと守ってます
だからといって その誰にでも
僕 一般的に守ってるこの生き方がどのように解脱になるのかということなんです
ね それだけで解脱に悟られますかね？ということです
だから嘘つかないだけで
解脱に悟れますかね 悟れますかね
どうですかね 悟れますよ
ただ 言葉に気を付けるだけでも悟りに達します
あの八正道に正命という言葉があるんです
命というのは命という漢字書いてますけど
あれは仕事ということなんです
正しい仕事をするだけ悟りに達しますよ
それだったらありがちゃいます
みんな悟ってますね だって法律を犯して仕事してるわけじゃないでしょ
銀行強盗をやってこちら来てないでしょ
お前 だから銀行強盗やったりとかね
そんな法律を犯して 皆様誰一人も仕事してないんです
まあ百万人に一人一人ぐらいはね
法律を犯して ちょっと悪いことをして生計を立ててるかもしれませんだけど
他の方々はみんな合法的な仕事で生計を立ててますよ
だから正命を守ってますよ
ポイントは では あなたは取れますかね
それ そんな程度 それなんですよ
このお釈迦様おっしゃっているのは
悟れますよ ただ嘘つかない
それだけで 背教から殺生をやめますと
ただ それだけの道徳を守ることででも
涅槃に解脱に悟りに達します
一切の苦しみを乗り越えられるんです
究極の幸福に達する 実現することができます
それに際しては 善友のアドバイスが必要なんです
その場合は この善友がやっぱり照準剣を握っているんです
これなんですよ 今日のポイント
八正道ならもう仏教であっても
仏教徒でなくても守られます
それで他宗教の方々も
まあブッダの八正道には誰も異論を抱きませんよ
八正道なんかはケチくさいんやとかね
言う人は世の中にいませんよ
だからといっても まあそれなりに誰でも守ってはいるんだけど
悟りに達しないところはポイントなんですね
悟りに達したければ やはり善友のアドバイスが必要です
善友がついてくると この初めてのこの
この聖なる道 これなんです
だからお釈迦様はそこをおっしゃったんです
この経典で あの 八正道のところではなくて
あり終わった感じ こうある
ありあっていること カリーャナミッタッセタンアーナンダ
ビックーノーパーティカンカン
カリーャナサーラーヤッサ
カリーャナサンパワンカンサ
アリーャンアッタンディカンマッガンバハーウェッサティ
アリーャンアッタンディカンマッガンバブニーカラセティ
はい このパーリの文章では
この私は今ギャーギャーギャーギャーと言ったポイントはないんです
次にお釈迦様それ止まっています
どのように八正道を実践するのか
今日はそこをカットします
なかなか私は全優じゃないんですよ
それを入れちゃったら
皆様もし悟りに達しちゃったらね
もう困りますからね はい
次の問題 この学ぶということをちょっと学んでみましょう
生まれてくる生命に死にたくはないという本能があります
死を避けるために何をすれば良いのかと
わずかに知る本能もあります
誰でも死にたくないですから
だから死なないために
なんとかなんとかどうすればいいんだという微かなかすかな知恵があります
しかし その本能だけでは生き続けることは決してできません
私たち人間で生まれても
赤ちゃんは母乳を吸った方がいい
その程度は知ってますよ
しかし それだけの能力で生き進むことはできませんよ
お母さんがずっとあれこれをやって手を加えて守ってあげないと死んでしまっちゃいます
赤ちゃんは命を守るために
なんか危ないなと分かったらじゃーと泣くんです
その能力はありますけど
泣くだけでそれ以外何もできません
だから命を守れませんよ
もうちょっと勉強してもらわないと
赤ちゃんの場合はお母さんに付いてるんだから大丈夫ですよ
ギャーッと泣いちゃうと
あ 子供が大変だということで守ってあげたりはする
それで赤ちゃんのレベルを覚えてください
我々が生まれる時は わずかな能力が本能としてついています
生きたければ母乳を吸わなくちゃいけないんだな
命を危険なものに出会ったら
命を守らなくちゃいけないんだな
だったら思い存分泣けと
ぐらいは教えられても一応あの心に刻んであるいます
本能 だから問題は 赤ちゃんが思い存分泣いたんだからといって
それで命が守られますか
あの 何回もあったケースなんですけど
この赤ちゃんをゴミ箱に捨てちゃったりして
日本でも時々やっちゃいます
あるいは駐車場で そのままもう冬であろうが全然関係なく
そのまま置いておいて出ていきます
それで子供はそうやって捨てるのは良くないでしょう
殺すのは良くないでしょ
いらん子供だったらもうあすか
なんて言いますか なんかどこか病院でポストを作ったんですね
赤ちゃんポスト 子供はいらんと思ったら
そのポストに投げ込めばいいんです
ポストでいったとしても
その向こう側 ちゃんと赤ちゃん用のベッドがありますから
そこの中に入れて くすっと出ていけばいい
そこに病院の人々は赤ちゃんの調子を見て
ちゃんと面倒を見て育てるということ
それには日本は猛反対していたんですね
やっぱり赤ちゃんがいらなくなったら捨てるできないです
ゴミ箱で 猛反対してたんですけど
それをまだまだやってます
まあとにかく私が言いたいのはそういうことじゃなくて
この人が行かない あまり人が行かない駐車場っていうのは車でしか行かないでしょ
そういうところで赤ちゃんが置かれても
寒くてものすごくね もう脱水状態になっちゃうしね
それでもこの子供たちは泣くんだからね
ものすごい声 誰かでした
だから結構赤ちゃんがもう森に駐車場に捨てられても
じゃーっと泣きますからね
それもよくよくタイミング見て泣くんでしょうね
いつでもずっと泣きっぱなしでちゃったら
それで捨てられちゃって終わりますから
それもしません タイミングよく泣くんです
ギャーギャーギャーギャーと泣いて
またジーッと止まっていて
まだ そうすると まあ誰か大人に見つかる可能性はあります
悲しいことに 日本で狼じゃないんだからね
狼がいたら狼が早く見つかりますけどね
で 一応 赤ちゃんはこの泣くという能力から能力を持ってもらって
なんとか死なない程度に人生は守ってはいるんですが
それだけの能力では生き続けません
これ 人間だけではなくて
動物にもありますよ 子猫ちゃんはだいたい動くものを見たらグチャグチャグチャグチャ遊んだりするのですね
ですから 狩りをする能力はいくらかはあります
しかし この人間と何かグチャグチャ動くもので遊んだだけでは狩りはできませんよ
実際の現場で獲物を追って追って
狩りをする能力はまた別に学ばなくてはいけないのです
しかし 必要な本能だけはついています
これは虎であろうが ライオンであろうが
象さんであろうが 牛であろうが
もう関係なく 生命はやっぱり学ばなくちゃいけないんですよ
命を続けるために学ぶために必要なベース
一番基本的な ほんのちょっとだけは持っています
ですから 学ぶということは
生命にとってはもう絶対的不可欠な仕事なんです
生まれてから学ばなくてはならないのです
ですから 生まれてから死ぬまで
絶えず学ばなくてはいけない
はい それと友人の関係は何やというと
友人から学ぶのです 学ぶことと
今まで善行と言ってきたんですけど
これが親友になっちゃうんです
あの言葉 両方使います
こう 経験がある人 先輩が後輩に教えるのです
それで我々人間には学ばなくてはいけない
誰から学んでもらうかというと
先輩から 経験のある人から学んでもらいます
決して私は小学生の1年生のところに行って何か教えてちょうだいとは言わないでしょ
文字 文字の書き方を教えてちょうだいとか
数え方を教えてちょうだいとか言わないんです
逆です 我々大人が小学生の子供たちに数え方とか教えてあげます
だから学ぶ場合はもう関係に言ってますよ
先輩 経験者が後輩に 未経験者に教える
この関係は師弟関係ではなく
親友関係だと仏教は説く
ここがポイント 教えてもらうんだったら向こうは先生でしょ
そうすると師弟関係でしょ
仏教は師弟関係という言葉を使いますけど
仏教であるのは親友関係なんです
なんかどうってことないような気がしますね
だから何って しかし これとっても大事なんです
はい 師弟関係じゃないんです
全然 あるべきなのは親友関係なんです
親友から学んでもらうんです
親友とは師の事です だから師匠なんです
師匠に親友というんです
これから皆様が何かね
伝統的な何かあの師匠から学んでるんだったら
師匠を紹介する場合は
これが私の親友です 紹介してください
クビになるかもしれませんだけどね
だって仏教ってことじゃないんだからね
仏教の世界ではもう親友でよろしいです
ブラフマーティマーターピトのプッバーチャリオとウッチこの仏教ではよくあの言われる言葉で
だから意味をどこかに取った
書いておかなかった 場所がないんです
で 意味は両親とはこれとって神であり
最初の師匠であるということ
お釈迦様は両親を慈悲く父親
母親を敬いなさいと言っているんです
この母父を敬いなさいという場合は
この言葉によるんです
母と父とは神様である
あの全知全能の神様である
それからあなたの最初の師匠です
だから敬いなさい はい
これから次のポイントに飛びます
それで 親が最初の師匠なりという言葉から
仏教が推薦する親友善友はどのような存在ですかと理解することができます
これで理解できるでしょ
皆様のお母様が皆様の師匠なんです
だから逆に師匠なるものはお母さんと同じでなければいけません
では お母さんお父さんってどんなものですかね
親は無条件に我が子を慈しむ
心配する 成長すること
幸福になることを期待するんです
我々のお母さんとお父さんという
この二人は無条件に子供のことを心配する
心配するはするは切りがないんです
これは人類どこでも 外国人でも
ヨーロッパ人でも アジア人でも
日本人でも 子供のことは心配する
子供の成長は期待する
願う あまりにも慈しみがあるんです
子に対しては 自分の我が子が自分を超えて超えて成長すると
あれほど楽しいことはないんです
お母さんがみんなにいじめられて生活していても
そのお母さんの子供がこれが一番人気者になっているならば
お母さんにはそれでも十分です
自分がけなけなけなされても
殴られても全然気にしません
それでも構いません うちの子は頑張っている
そういう風な このまた不思議な慈しみを両親持ってるんです
子供に対して この師匠も同じ性格でなければいけませんよ
師匠も我が弟子に対して
何としてでも成長してほしいと
何としてでも成功してほしいと
何としてでも学問を身につけてほしいと
その無条件な慈しみが師匠にもあるべきなんです
だから善行っていうのは
ですから わかりやすい
母親のような人なんです
父親のような人なんです
そう世の中でいうわけじゃないんです
そんな言い方は言えないんです
師匠イコール善友は親のような存在でなくてはならないんです
はい 次 世間論に入ります
世間の親友と異なる なんか文章一つ抜けてます
善友とはね 善友とは世間の親友のことになります
善人は明らかに先輩であり
経験と知識は自分より上なのです
ちょっとおかしくなった
ちょっとややこしくなったんでしょうかね
あの 学んでもらうんだからね
善友から だから善友はいつでも年上
目上なんです 目上なんです
いくら頑張っても息子娘は親よりも立派じゃないんです
子供にとっては親が断然偉いんです
子供が総理大臣になっても
お母さんはお母さんだからね
それは変わらない だから両親と子供のこの関係はいつたっても変わりません
はい 善友っていうのは覚えておいてください
仏教が説く善友っていうのは
いつでも両親と同じく目上なんです
自分を指導して導くものなのです
世間で言う友人は仲間なんです
はい これからごちゃ混ぜにしないでください
皆様方 友達がいる 友達がいる
友達言ってるでしょ 一人も善友ではありませんよ
私には友達はもう 120人いますよ
あの いい人といますよ
朝目が覚めるとすぐメールを送るんです
それからメールを送るわ
からご飯食べるとこメールを送るわ
エスカレーターに乗っている時にメールを送るわ
もうお布団に入ってはメールを送って
もう何回も送って それから寝るんです
それでまたもう手に携帯をいくらでもあるんです
そばに 目が覚めた それからまた友達にメールを送ろう
結構友達がいるもんですね
まあせいぜい数えてみれば 4人ぐらいですけどね
朝から晩までメールを送るんだけどね
とにかく たまに私には 100人も友達がいるんだよという人がいるかもしれません
しかし 友達は 100人いようが
500人いようが 全人の友達がいようが
善友ではないんです みんな仲間なんです
自分と同格なんです 自分が困ることになったら
友人も一緒に困るだけで同調するだけです
例えば友達同士で一人が困っちゃったら
もう一人の友達もやっぱり困っちゃったねとかね
どうしようかとか そんなもんでしょう
友達のなんとかペットでも死んじゃったら
友達が泣いちゃうと友達が不幸
もう一人の友達もやっぱり悲しいですねとか言うだけ
同感なんです 何かをしてあげる
導く能力はありません
これだけは覚えてほしいんです
世の中 皆様にも友達がいるでしょうに
いくら友達がいても 我々は困ったことになったら
導くこと アドバイスする能力はないんです
我々は困ったら友達も困ったねとかね
真面目に困ってくれるんです
それ役に立たないけどね
そんなことを友達のね
例えば親が死んじゃって
あるいは旦那さんが死んじゃって
あるいは子供が死んじゃって
友達がものすごく落ち込んでいると
友達家に来て そばに座ってじーっとしてるんですね
友達は喋る 無口 もう悶々として喋る気もない
もう親しい人が死んじゃったのに
そこで自分のこと心配する友達が家に来て
本人も座ってじーっとしてるんです
だから友達ってのはそんなもんなんですよ
それでなんとなくその二人でね
気持ちがどんどん明るくなってきたら
まあお茶飲んだりご飯食べたりはする
だから自然に心が外されてもらうであって
何か助けてあげることはできないんです
友達っていうのは真面目にね
困ったねと言うだけ やっぱり誤解しないでください
これは悪い友達わけじゃないですよ
友達の能力はその程度なんでしょう
例えば中学の 2年生の子供に同じクラスの友達がいるとしますね
それで難しい宿題にぶつかっちゃって
もう困ってるんですよ
それ友達に聞くんです
あのね これってややこしいでしょ
言ったら 向こうもうーん
そうですね これってまずいなとかね
これ難しいな わからへんねとかね
二人で困るだけ だって二人で同じクラスだからどうしようもないでしょ
はい 世の中の友達っていうのは同感の人々なんです
仲間なんです 善友ではないんです
Give and Takeの関係で成り立っているんですね
友達関係 互いに補うことで順調に生きることはできますが
我々は Give and Takeの世界で
私にないものは外からいただいて
外にないものを私からあげて
Give and Takeで結構順調に生きているんです
大胆に成長することは期待できない
これは Give and Takeの世界で
人類が突然壁を破って成長する
発展するということはありません
世間の対等の友人が自分を指導することになると
結果は喧嘩です 友人関係は壊れます
例えば自分の友達がね
アドバイスすることになったら
自分では私はあなたにアドバイスします
私言う通りにやってください
私に従いなさいと言ったら
なんだお前って蹴っ飛ばして蹴っ飛ばしたくなるんです
何様のつもりですか？まずいんです
友達同士で 友達同士で
一人がもう一人にアドバイスするっていうことは
これは間抜けです お互い様平等だからね
友人もそれから別なやっぱり友人を選ぶ基準
まあ堕落する意図がある
悪を犯すための人間関係は悪友との関わりになります
シンプルでしょう あの
自分が堕落するならばね
友達の関係 それは悪友でしょう
やめた方がいいです 互いの人生に役に立つための友人関係は親友というものです
この場合は親友という単語はちょっと使いにくいですけど
善友良い友達だから 善友は別に使ってるんだから
ここを使えないんですよね
悪に対する善ですからね
もう単語足らなくなっちゃって
だから親友にしたんです
あの お互い助け合って
幸せに幸せで生活できるならば
まあ親友ですね 例えば例えばパチンコの仲間は親友ではなく
勉強の仲間は親友になるんです
パチンコに行くための仲間がいるならば
あまりいい友達じゃないんですね
その人間関係はパチンコに行って遊ぶだけのことだからね
だから飲み仲間とかいろいろいるでしょ
悪友たちが だからそれは気をつけてください
それ以外はもう勉強の仲間
仕事の仲間 稽古の仲間とかね
お互い成長する作業においての仲間は信用できるんです
道徳と人生の成功を基準にして基準にして考えるなら
ならば友人を選ぶ問題は解決です
こんな簡単でいいんですかね
友人 友人を選ぶということはあまりにも簡単です
自分の役に立つか この人と付き合って何かいいことでもあるのか
それだけなんです それから道徳
この人と付き合っちゃうと
やっぱり万引きしたくなるんだよ
その人だとも付き合わない方がいいです
この人と付き合うと いろいろ会社の金ごまかすずるがしこい知恵を教えてくれるんだよ
とだったらやめてください
道徳を犯すためのやり方教えてくれる友達は
もうとんでもない友達じゃないんです
悪人です 単純です 例えば
料理の仕方を教えてくれる
ジャガイモの簡単な皮のむき方
こんなものやとね 教えてくれる人々で十分です
あるいはある奥さんがね
私はあなたにね ジャガイモを均等に切る方法を教えてあげますよ
あの機械使わずに玉ねぎのみじん切り
なんか透明に見えるようなぐらいみじん切りする方法があります
機械も使わないでよく教えてあげます
そんな程度の なんとか人生に役に立つことを教えてくれる友達関係で十分でしょう
あまりにもシンプルですね
まあちょっと難しくします
それでは友人の数 必要なものが補うできものをがたくさんある人は
自分で進んで友人をたくさん作らなくて
たくさん作らなくてはならないんです
与えることがたくさんある人に
自然に友人がたくさんついてきます
早く終わってくださいってことがありますから
しかし 人の能力に限りがあるので
管理できる範囲で友人の数を決めるべきです
あの 自分にたくさんいろんなことを学ばなくてはいけないし
いろんなものが必要だったら
自分で進み たくさん友達を作るわけになります
自分がいろんなものを持って
いろんな能力を持っていると
あげるものがたくさんあると
友達っていうのは勝手に現れてきます
だから それよりも自分で管理できる範囲の人数を決めた方がいいんです
友人がいることでこの自由は揺らぐので要注意です
友人がいただけでありがたくないんですよ
友人がいる 自分の自由が結構もうなくなるんです
だからそこら辺で中道を考えた方がいいんです
人間は個人としてもプライバシーというか
自由が必要なんです だからそれは完全壊すな
壊すまで友人関係を作る必要はないのです
はい 友人の区別 自分を導く善友イコール師匠はカリヤーナミッタとパーリ語で呼ばれます
あの善 カリヤーナ 善友というのはいつでも師匠なんです
カリヤーナとは良い 素晴らしいという意味です
生活に当てはめると 今より優れた状態という意義になります
だからカリヤーナミッタっていうのは
善友っていうのは自分を今よりレベル高くしてくれる人なんです
世間のレベルの友人 親友はスハッジャミッタというふうにパーリ語
心に近いという意味なんですね
あの英語の単語でクロースフレンドという言葉がありますね
もう心に近い 仲良しという意味なんです
だから仏教では仲良しと善友というのは二つなんです
今 今日の講演で言いたいのは
仲良しはいくらでもいますよ
善友っていうのは格が違うんです
はい